It's worth noting that although we changed some keywords--
they had a different spelling where it's almost as if
we had to translate them into a different language--
the underlying meaning was the same in both languages.
We can translate programs, functions between Python and JavaScript
provided that we know both of them.
In linguistics, people will sometimes talk about a universal grammar
as there may be some grammar that would sit behind and describe Python,
JavaScript, English, and French.
I don't want to get into that for natural languages,
but we will see either in this class or in subsequent ones,
that for computer languages like Python or JavaScript, C and C++,
Visual Basic, C Sharp, OCaml, Free Basic, they're all the same in a very strong sense.
They're all Turing-complete.
I'm not going to much detail now, but it suffices to say that Python
and JavaScript are equally powerful.
Any thought that I can think in one I can also think in the others.
Now I'm going to bite the bullet and actually write out a partial grammar for JavaScript.
This is only a partial grammar because it only handles expressions,
and it only handles some of the expressions.
An expression can either be an identifier--like a variable name x or a function
like sine or absval,
a number--1, 3.5, -2, a string--like "hello" in quotes,
literal constants--like True or even False.
These are the equivalent of numbers,
but for the Booleans there are only two numbers--True and False--
and then a large number of binary operators.
If you have two expressions, you can add them together, subtract them,
multiply them, divide them--watch out for division by zero.
You can compare them to see if one is less than the other.
You can compare them to see if they're exactly equal.
If they're Booleans, you can check to see if the first is true and the second is true.
Just a little note--if you haven't run into this before--
two ampersands means "and" and two vertical bars means "or."
In Python where you might write and or or, in JavaScript you use these
binary operator symbols instead.
Just as we have less than here, there'd also be greater than, greater than or equal to,
less than or equal to, and many more.
This JavaScript expression grammar should be familiar to you,
because aside from some minor details of spelling like the equal signs here
or the capital word "TRUE" to mean true.
It should be very similar to Python.